Avec le confinement,
on s'est tous mis à la cuisine.
Mais pourquoi pleure-t-on quand on épluche un oignon ?
Quand on coupe, le liquide qui se trouve
à l'intérieur se vaporise.
Ce gaz monte et arrive au voisinage de nos yeux.
Ce gaz contient du soufre qui réagit avec l'eau.
Au contact du liquide lacrymal, essentiellement de l'eau, qui enrobe et protège nos yeux,
le souffre se transforme en acide sulfurique.
Ça pique ! du coup on pleure pour se protéger.
Mais plus il y a de larmes, plus on active la réaction
plus le souffre se transforme en acide sulfurique
Ça pique encore plus et on pleure encore plus !
C'est une chaîne sans fin.
La solution : couper l'oignon à proximité d'un filet d'eau.
Le gaz est piégé avant d'arriver à nos yeux
ou plus radical : le masque !
C'est plus ridicule aussi mais ça me permet de venir
à bout de cette "capsule de déconfiné".
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces"capsules de déconfiné"
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...